bonsoir bonsoir
battre Giscard destin changer changer
vraiment tel est mon objectif tel est le
sens de ma candidature à l'élection
présidentielle il est significatif
d'ailleurs que le tirage au sort m'est
désigné comme le premier candidat qui
s'adresse ce soir à
vous naturellement
vous connaissez le bilan de la politique
giscardienne de son
sepéna c'est la raison pour laquelle
durant mes émissions de télévision je
n'entends pas m'y
arrêter je considère en effet que les
chômeurs par exemple n'ont pas besoin
qu'on leur explique que le chômage est
un drame pour eux-mêmes pour leur
famille pour la
nation les familles populaires qui ont
du mal à vivre à boucler leur budget à
la fin du mois n'ont pas besoin qu'on
leur explique qu'il est dur de se priver
de priver ses enfants parfois sur
l'essentiel par conséquent j'entends
pour ce qui me concerne me consacrer à
ce qui est essentiel à savoir peut-on
sortir le pays de la crise peut-on
mettre un terme au chômage peut-on
assurer le progrès social peut-on
résoudre les grands problèmes poser à
notre peuple que ce soit dans le domaine
de la santé de l'école du logement
peut-on satisfaire les besoins et les
aspirations de la paysannerie
laborieuse ma réponse est oui trois
moyens pour atteindre cet objectif ces
objectifs le premier moyen il faut des
choix clairs nets et précis autrement
dit des objectifs correspondant aux
intérêts aux aspirations des Françaises
et des Français des objectifs mais aussi
les moyens de les atteindre c'est ce que
j'ai fait avec mes 131 propositions qui
ont été largement diffusé dans tout le
pays
le deuxème moyen il faut un mouvement
populaire largement
majoritaire un mouvement populaire qui
trouve son prolongement dans l'union de
la gauche et jusqu'à y compris dans un
gouvernement socialiste communiste c'est
ce que nous voulons et nous sommes prêts
nous les communistes à assumer toutes
nos responsabilités à la direction des
affaires du pays 3è moyen
et bien il faudra lutter vous le savez
par
expérience jamais la bourgeoisie jamais
le patronat ne vous ont accordé quelque
avantage que ce soit si vous ne l'avez
imposé par la lutte ceux qui vous
promettent de vous apporter le bonheur
sur un plateau d'argent ceux qui vous
disent votez pour moi et après je ferai
le reste ce sont des démagogues
moi au contraire je m'adresse à vous en
vous disant en définitive la clé du
changement c'est vous qui l'avez entre
vos mains et bien c'est à ces trois
moyens là que j'entends donc consacré
mes
explications pourquoi mais parce que je
veux que les Français et les Français le
26 avril au premier tour puisse se
prononcer se déterminer en toute
connaissance de cause lorsqu'ils iront
dans l'isoloir c'est pourquoi il est
nécessaire d'avoir un grand débat
démocratique j'ai déjà parlé à plus de
600000 personnes dans mes Réunion et à
la télévision j'entends m'adresser à
vous avec la même franchise la même
honnêteté parce qu'en définitive oui je
le répète c'est de vous que tout dépend
votre avenir l'immédiat votre avenir
l'avenir de la France il est entre vos
mains c'est dire toute l'importance de
cette élection
présidentiel qui peut enclencher le
changement dont vous avez besoin et
auquel vous
aspireer